okay the question is in surah fool
wanted but it speaks about it speaks
about Jesus then says that he puts
someone in the place of Jesus Christ on
the cross to die
okay now you have a person is a
Christian is
this means a million
I'm a point one Jesus message okay now
you see petitions of this fee when god
almighty Allah's Fontana look Jeeva and
tasted so far okay I agree yes now won't
you
genius please be uploaded came down yes
even if we look into the Bible and many
places Jesus said he loved Israel I will
notice one my father is greater than I
and I see I judge my judgment is just
because I don't seek my will by the will
of my father Jesus always returned to
the Father
Ricola for the father or the father even
in the book of Acts chapter 2 verse 22
he says hear o Israel
Jesus of Nazareth a man approved by God
with wondrous miracles and signs which
God made by meaning Jesus was chosen
just like Moses and Abraham are the
messengers to do works on behalf but
that does not make him good so now when
we look into the scripture that Jesus
came with yeah Jesus came with in the
scriptures we can clearly see jesus
never claims divinity the challenge is
being therefore very one shows one place
we Jesus said I am God worship me now
the question comes to this you are
saying that Christians you're saying the
Christians were deceived
how did they get this receive when Jesus
himself has said in many places I am NOT
God Here I am NOT God he has never
spoken about I would die on the cross
for your sins he hasn't said that so
when Jesus comes to you and teaches to
the Jewish and says look what is one he
doesn't talk about dying for you Rob
blah blah and then there was Christian
Unitarian Christians right words of the
Living God Almighty alone right and if
you don't believe this concept of Jesus
that for our sins they are the true
people who believe in Jesus Christ
however you're seeing no they were
perceived by your birth come in and
changing places no because when Jesus
came he said for this
I'm not going to die for your sins so
any person is disciple follows his
commandments would know that so when
somebody gets killed in his place
there's no deceiving going on because
they believe he's dilettante attacked my
sins
he's given cream divine his God Almighty
he even talked about somebody that will
come
so the real people through Jesus will
never believe he pushing their way from
alabaster but whereas Paul came in and
other scriptures got changed when Jesus
died for our sins that's when he was
fired to not follow the scriptures right
and went with their own desires we're in
the plan Alice Montana says woe to those
who write the book with their own hands
scripture so that's why they haven't
been the same because the followers of
Jesus
[Applause]
Jesus wasn't going to that said that
Jesus here did not tell them he never
told her you know you never told them
never told
okay so the question is this did the
people believe according to crime
there's in the same that they thought
they believed that he died before he
died but he did not that
okay so in other words those people are
there they actually believed they were
the happiest misconception here use
understand is what everyone's there for
but they believe that he's as white
because they understood that Jesus told
the cross what happened he was switched
over
switched up and Simeon took his place
him to their agreement he was she was a
celebrity news the way to the cross okay
the thing is this is actually pretty
kids
[Music]
an exchange diminishing into heaven okay
I put someone else in his place making
other people think
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay the day I was born and the day I
die and the day I will die yes I was
born the day I die
wait wait when he comes back he's gonna
live and he's gonna die
and when you die one of us is gonna be
who's resurrected
but we do know how just tell us so okay
so for the benefit of people watching it
is Allah be upon him peace upon him day
he was born and the day he dies
this is
okay now you said what to see the fish
because it will place Jesus you see
today we have 2 billion Christians and
only that did not have the ability to
pull after us
my seam Jesus came with the teachings of
Sadie's God Almighty he never said he's
gonna die on the cross so the people got
really followed him
look if not believe his God Almighty
would have not been easy that the demon
was replaced today through they would
not believe he died on the cross the
chief arose wait for another person
that's coming to Jesus said that there
will be another person dies coming
the ones that will deceive are the ones
the ones that are deceived today are the
ones who know his scriptures where Alice
was that it says woe to those who
changes to their own reasons it is from
put okay you chose to do it don't
believe how he fairly the chief
scriptures they would not believe Jesus
on the cross for our sins because he's
never said Talley I don't think we've
seen one I'm doing what I think I'm
showing you that there is a major
contradiction
do you don't see that as a monk at one
part two cities died you didn't say how
would you
yes yeah okay so anyway okay yeah yeah
so these people
they know
these are the truth people that worship
God alone
yeah the real real Christians that we
can stay that worship of the Lord do not
believe Jesus that variance then again
Paul comes when you can be poor know
Jesus I mean I know then I go this one
is now the vision is come the people
have been following the news pictures
and the one that gonna believe porn he
was a bounty hunter is the questions now
the division starts and after hear me
these tougher new import these guys go
Nana Nana Nana we stick into what Jesus
told us and there's gonna be another
profit coming right so what is this the
wonderful applause are you today and the
ones that were of the view scriptures
are the ones that became Muslims over
and over again two times today the
system
you